kaum eine andere sportart hat so eine
krasse spannweite von meditativen
alleine spielen zu hause oder zusammen
mit freunden als klassiker des kalten
sport bis hin zu es kreativen mega
events bei denen die plus von unmengen
an fans bejubelt werden und dabei ist
die idee von das doch eigentlich schon
fast so sind will ich meinen mann hilft
nur ein paar pfeile auf eine scheibe
oder naja fast das ziel beim klassischen
tat ist es sich von 501 punkten
herunterzuspielen auf exakt null wobei
immer die punktzahl die man trifft
abgezogen wird zusätzlich gibt es auf
dem brett den dar in dem die punkte wie
der name schon sagt verdoppelt werden
und den typischen indem sie verdreifacht
werden außerdem gibt es noch das auto
wohl das 25 punkte zählt und dass er
bald mit 50 die spieler haben pro runde
drei würfe in einer perfekten runde kann
man also maximal 180 punkte werfen
dreimal die triple 20
[Applaus]
die regelmäßig zu treffen gelingt sogar
den besten der besten nicht immer der
weltrekord für die beste
durchschnittspunktzahl pro runde also
wohl drei würfen liegt bei knapp 123 es
geht aus und selbst bei profis
mindestens jeder dritte wurf daneben mal
schauen ob bzw wie weit ich dann mit
einer woche training hin kommen und ob
ich das nächste mal beim greifen da hat
meine freunde vernichten kann um das zu
vergleichen werde ich am anfang 100
würfel machen und am ende 100 würfe und
dann schauen ob sich mein durchschnitt
verbessert dieses video wird unterstützt
von schocks als erstes brauche ich aber
natürlich eine dartscheibe uns da ich
ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen respekt
vor diesen metallspitzen habe ich mir
vor ein paar tagen erstmal eine
elektronische gestellt mit diesen
plastik spitzen erzählt dann auch gleich
automatisch die punkte mit nun wird die
dartscheibe aufgegangen und da ich
bestimmt oft daneben treffen werde und
auch mit den stumpfen fallen keine wende
treffen will und auch keine mitarbeiter
wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss
ich bin so froh dass ich diese woche von
zu hause gearbeitet habe packen wir
sicherheitshalber eine große holzplatte
hinter die scheibe und messen an die
korrekten abstände aus das sind 1 x 1
meter 73 vom boden bis zum bulls sowie
die mitte der deutsche genannt wird und
zwei meter 44 dann von der scheibe bis
zum abwurf punkt und massenweise das
muss natürlich auch noch zusammengebaut
werden bevor unsere eigene data station
fertig ist er ist jetzt aber an die
erste bestandsaufnahme meiner
fähigkeiten mit dem durchschnitt aus 100
dürfen geht werde ich mich zuerst auch
und zwar mit einem spiel gegen alle und
luan während die profis übrigens von 500
einem punkt runter spielen und das spiel
mit einem treffer in den doppeln beenden
müssen spielen wir erstmal nur von 300
und 1 unter und müssen nicht mit einem
doppel beenden weil die runden sonst
stunden dauern würden
frau die ein
ich glaube nicht dass ich noch mal
[Musik]
verliehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich werde zweiter geworden als ob wir
noch viel luft nach oben jetzt muss ich
allerdings nach dieser kleinen auf 100
meine durchschnittspunktzahl auf 100
höfe gerechnet und sagt komplett ohne
vorkenntnisse und kliniken oder e-mails
oder einmal drauf los
[Musik]
was
bist dass du
was ich war damals so hat also die
einstellung eines chauffeurs
[Musik]
als vorletzten training kann jetzt
eigentlich noch schlechter werden
aber kraft direkt 202 mio größer als das
fiese ist dass neben der hohen 20 die
niedrige 5 und die noch schlimmere 1
liegen dh auf die treppe 20 zu gehen ist
auch immer ziemlich riskant entweder man
kriegt 60 punkte oder auch eben auch nur
einen und so treffe ich zwar einige male
die 20 und zweimal sogar die 60 aber
eben auch sehr sehr oft nur die 1
lustigerweise so gut wie immer mit einem
zweiten burg und deshalb bin ich jetzt
wie es aussieht vor einem
durchschnittswert von 14,37 probe also
mal 3 gibt es da einen 43 pro durchgang
gar nicht mal so schlecht aber da wird
einem erst einmal klar wie krass die
sehr rekord durchschnitt von 123 ist
ultra spannend finde ich auch diese
grafik zur verteilung meiner treffer ich
habe zwar auch die 20 gezählt aber die
treffer sind eigentlich kreuz und quer
verteilt und ich habe gefühlt öfter aus
versehen das bullseye getroffen als das
was ich treffen wollte an der auswertung
hier sieht man auch dass nur neun
prozent aller treffer überhaupt auf den
20 gegangen sind da wo ich sie haben
wollte und zum beispiel 13 prozent
reinem auf die 18 ich bin gespannt ob
ich diese verteilung noch deutlich mehr
richtungen trip mit 20 konzentrieren
kann innerhalb der nächsten sechs tage
normalerweise spielt mandate ein
geselliger runde mit freunden aber wenn
man hier stundenlang auf die scheibe
wirft dann kann das schon mal schnell
langweilig werden deshalb höre ich
generell beim sport gerne herrlicher
musik und podcasts 20 sportarten ist
allerdings nicht ganz von vorteil wenn
man komplett abtaucht und gar nichts
mehr hört da kann es schon mal von
vorteil sein mit willkommen was um einen
herum passiert oder vielleicht will man
auch einfach nur seinen trainingspartner
verstehen schocks der sponsor des videos
hat sich um das problem zu beheben auf
kopfhörer spezialisiert die nicht mit
gewöhnlichen kopfhörer den ton mittels
luft schwingungen durch den gehörgang
übertragen sondern einfach direkt per
vibration an wangenknochen das
funktioniert echt mega gut und ich meine
das ist überhaupt funktioniert ist schon
echt mega crazy weil man hört musik
dabei einfach über seine knochen der
aktuell zehn stunden und lebt in nur
fünf minuten genug auf für anderthalb
stunden hördauer und regen und staub
sind dank der ip 55 zertifizierung auch
kein problem mit schocks auto sitzen
echt mega bequem und fest und sind
trotzdem klein und leicht was die
perfekt für jeden sport macht klickt auf
den link in der video beschreibung für
mehr informationen zu den shops open
rand pro und deren kontakten technologie
das sind die westlichsten schocks
kopfhörer die es bisher gab übrigens
könnt ihr jetzt unter dem video ein von
sechs trucks open rand pro gewinn mehr
infos findet ihr im angeführten
kommentare nachdem ich gestern abend
noch ein bißchen frieden hat habe ich
jetzt total muskelkater hier im bizeps
ich weiß gar nicht wie so erschreckend
weil man immer damit seinen arm stoff
also ist schon echt krass weil ich komme
es im schnitt schon super oft hier so
ein damit sich von diesem typen dingo
und dass das jetzt irgendwie nur einem
tag möglich war ist gegen mich schon
ziemlich komisch
[Musik]
also zwei zu beschleunigen einer drei
erfolge ist schon wirklich hart und ich
glaube das beste was ich bisher immer
geschafft als ich danach zum spaß ein
spiel gegen alle gespielt habe habe ich
wenn auch nur knapp verloren das
hauptziel in dieser woche ist das
möglichst oft die 20 und töpfe 20 zu
treffen um auf eine maximale hohe
durchschnittspunktzahl zu trainieren in
den spielen gegen andere scheitert erst
an aber häufig an der zielsicherheit was
andere felder angeht denn wenn man
gewinnen will muss man am ende der runde
mit einer punktlandung auf null kommen
und darf zum beispiel nicht mit einer
tüte 20 übers ziel hinaus schießt
[Musik]
aktuell ganz gute performance heißt
also ich komme ja schon echt immer
ziemlich nahe eigentlich ich kann leider
auch super oft die 1 und ich glaube
jetzt ist es an der zeit an der zeit
sich mal ein bisschen rein zu lesen ob
seine tricks gibt
richtig freuen das habe ich ja schon mal
richtig machen
und lag 1 obergeschoss der front rechte
fuß nach vorne gewicht auch nach vorne
hinter das band zum stabilisieren nehmen
entspannte haltung dort halten wie ein
stift und zwar locker hat auf der höhe
meines rechten auges und der ellbogen
soll sich kaum bewegen
[Musik]
ich glaube das muss ich noch üben
also ich glaube es wird ein bisschen
dauern bis ich mich daran gewöhnt habe
weil ich habs jetzt anders quasi
eingeübt aber die partie war schon krass
erfolg also es ist echt ein komplett
anderes ding ich habe zweimal fast
training getroffen ich spiele also eine
woche lang jeden tag das oft alleine oft
aber auch gegen freunde und am kölner
karneval sogar gegen den dinosaurier
so langsam zeit sich die ganze aber aus
[Musik]
ich hatte am anfang an gesagt dass ich
mich noch nicht so richtig traut mit
metall da zu spielen das hat sich
mittlerweile ein bisschen geändert ich
bin mittlerweile deutlich treffsicherer
geworden entsprechend habe ich jetzt
halt hier diese metall darts und hier
ohne richtige scheibe
detoniert standard scheibe und ich muss
auch ehrlich sagen dass die
also das ding ist massiv das auch
richtig dick und häufig schwer hätte ich
nicht erwartet
boah ist das alles freilich
das geräusch so viel besser und macht so
viel weniger lärm ich würde sagen dann
hänge ich die mal aus
so meinen ersten richtigen platz
jetzt fühlt sich komplett anders an frau
ist geil
wieder einmal drinbleiben und nicht
warum backen und noch nicht raus fliegen
oder so ist auch macht
skyline
[Musik]
auch wenn die profis aber deutlich mehr
spaß macht hänge ich noch einmal die
elektronische an die wand für die finale
messung des fortschritts bin ich in
einer woche gemacht habe schaffe ich
jetzt auf 100 test würfe einen höheren
durchschnitt als an tag 1
let's go 100
bringt schon mal bruder
[Musik]
bisschen die einer kompensiert noch
die eins ist ich hätte mir zu und ich
glaube ich schreibe einmal auf die 20
eins drauf dann würde ich richtig
rasieren
da bin ich mal gespannt auf die
auswertung aber ich habe super oft 20
tropfen zum ende hin allerdings wolf
deutlich schlechter ich mache also
erstmal mit der verteilung dieser am
anfang so aus als sei sie kreuz und quer
und das sieht jetzt hinterher komplett
konzentrieren aus das ist richtig cars
also das ist viel ich bin viel genauer
geworden innerhalb von einer woche sind
eigentlich fast alle auf die 20 15 ein
paar noch auf acht zehn und zwölf
gegangen aber sind alle so richtig krass
konzentriert um die triple 20 herum ja
gut die tüte 20 selbst hat sich leider
nicht so oft getroffen einmal nur das
sieht so ein bisschen aus es werde ein
kraftfeld gewesen auf der b20 die alle
daten einmal weg geschoben hat weil
unten drüber links rechts sind überall
welcher wer da nicht auch jetzt hier in
der trefferquote auswertung bin ich so
viel besser geworden ich hatte davor nur
zu neun prozent die 20 getroffen die ich
hier immer anvisiert hat und jetzt zu 31
prozent das heißt fast jeder dritte
treffer geht dahin wo ich denn hin am
bild tatsächlich auf 25 prozent also
jeder vierte treffer ging auf die eins
was natürlich gar nicht gut ist ja der
iren neben der 20 lebt jetzt was puls
verspannt ist ja man sieht ja dass ich
eigentlich viel besser geworden bin ich
treffe viele häufige dahin wo ich die
eintritte welt meine
durchschnittspunktzahl ist allerdings
pro drei würfe also kohle von 43 wenn
ihr euch ändern könnt auf 38 sogar
gesunken das muss man sich mal auf der
zunge zergehen lassen und das ist schon
heftig einfach weil ich halt dadurch
dass ich die 20 anvisiert auch super auf
die eins treffen ja und scheinbar wenn
man kreuz und quer über die dartscheibe
ballert und auch mal so tippl 18
erwischt oder mal seine 19
dann hat man hören durchschnitt als
anfänger wenn ihr jetzt bock habt auf
neiße und sportlichen kopfhörer check
gerne link zu schocks aus und dann würde
ich sagen zunächst mal wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]